diet coke stay extraordinary
[Music]
hi conan o'brien here you know for eight
weeks i've been answering your questions
and you've had a lot of good ones
there's one question i haven't answered
it's the one i get the most often conan
what's your new show going to be like
rather than tell you i thought i'd show
you by doing an actual show
right now on the internet
problem is things on the internet have
to be fast so we're gonna do right now
something that's never been done before
the fastest talk show ever called
show zero
[Music]
[Music]
welcome now ladies and gentlemen
to show zero
andy announce me
all right here he is
conan o'brien
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much
welcome to the conference room at our
studio here at stage 15. uh now i
couldn't get the whole band for this
show this afternoon but please welcome
the 1 7th that really counts
jerry vavino
[Applause]
is that a piccolo is that what that is
all right it's like a fancy kazoo uh
like you have tinkerbell as a sidekick
yes it's very nice now let's start off
of course with the monologue joke
everyone likes their jokes check this
out bear with me oh okay caster somanya
the female south african runner found to
have male sex organs trying to raise
money using facebook
yeah she's the first
first ever facebook user to list their
gender as it's complicated
[Applause]
ah that's a good one boss all right
we're gonna have a lot of time so let's
get this thing started let's welcome our
first guest he's an emmy-winning actor
who plays sheldon cooper on the hit show
the big bang theory please welcome jim
parson
[Applause]
so
jim how's it going it's well it's nice
to be here for show zero
big bang theory airs thursday nights at
8 on cbs jim parsons
thank you it's good to talk to you thank
you so much
[Applause]
and now here's andy richter with a word
from our sponsor andy
diet coke you should drink it often
back to you conan
thanks a lot andy
and now for some music my next guest
hail from new jersey
here's their album here to play the
first chord off their self-titled album
please welcome steel train
one two three four
very nice guys steel train everybody
you wanna hear the whole thing get the
album
andy any other thoughts about diet coke
um
i once put a lemon in it and it was good
that way
back to you conan
thanks a lot andy
now stay tuned november 8th for the real
show on tbs
if you have any other questions go to
teamcoco.com
and uh now someone just got hurt
here to take us out is the dancing taco
see you november 8.
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys
thank you very much thank you for coming
thank you for being here thank you very
much
thank you guys so much thank you that's
actually a very good chord
[Music]
for you
[Music]
um
[Music]